elle commence à faire couler l'eau à
nous noyer dans la baignoire donc ça a
commencé par moi comme j'ai appelé ma
petite sœur au secours elle a été
récupérée ma sœur pour la noyée
également
à l'âge de 4-6 ans ma sœur et moi avons
été placée on a été enlevé à notre mère
je dirais puisque tout se passait très
bien avec notre mère avec notre famille
on perd tout repère on laisse ma mère on
laisse notre famille pour se retrouver
dans une immense maison on est accueilli
plutôt correctement au début et petit à
petit les choses se détériorent la
première fois c'est quand on a découvert
la fameuse scène avec la petite fille
lorsqu'on a découvert le bébé dans la
chambre et notre famille d'accueil en
train de lui enfoncer le bâton dans les
fesses d'un seul coup je crache je
l'insulte je me retrouve à essayer de
faire diversion pour qu'elle lâche pour
qu'elle lâche la petite finalement elle
finit par m'emmener dans la salle de
bain elle commence à faire couler l'eau
à nos loyers dans la baignoire donc ça a
commencé par moi comme j'ai appelé ma
petite sœur au secours elle a été
récupérée ma sœur pour la noyer
également c'est de là que tout les
sévics ont commencé elle nous a traînés
toutes nues après dans les escaliers
jusqu'au téléphone puisqu'on voulait
appeler notre mère un objet par terre à
côté du téléphone et on se retrouve
bloqué sans pouvoir téléphoner à notre
mère pour pouvoir lui dire
pas besoin d'elle tu te retrouves au sol
toute nue avec une serviette qu'elle t'a
balancé et tu t'es démuni de tout tu
peux rien faire c'est là que pour nous
ça a commencé véritablement maintenant
qu'on avait vu ce qui s'était passé il y
avait plus de on était dans l'envers du
décor ça y est c'était voilà c'était
comme ça on allait constamment être
torturé dormir dans la cave avoir des
douches froides au quotidien
interdiction de manger en famille
toujours enfermé dans la chambre j'avais
des étouffements à l'entonnoir j'étais
nourri par entonnoir c'était comme ça
tout le temps et nos journées c'était de
se réveiller avec la boule au ventre on
se demandant comment se déroulerait la
journée il y avait pas besoin de raison
particulière pour les tortures puisque
j'ai le souvenir de d'un enfermement
régulier dans le cellier ou elle me
maintenait du matin jusqu'au soir avec
un cahier de multiplication elle me
demandait de d'apprendre par cœur mes
tables or j'étais trop petite pour
pouvoir les connaître et elle me disait
tu vas rester toute la journée debout je
vais venir de récupérer en fin de
journée et tu passes la journée complète
dans une pièce où tu as des machines à
laver qui tournent en boucle et ça tape
toute la journée debout tu attendes tu
as envie de faire pipi ta faim tu as
peur tu attends quelqu'un vient te
délivrer la porte elle est fermée tu
dois attendre qu'elle t'ouvre le soir et
ce fameux soir là aussi également quand
elle a ouvert la porte elle me dit tu
vas choisir c'est soit le chausson ou
soit c'est la cave donc je voulais pas
aller dans la cave je voulais plus
dormir dans la cave donc je choisis le
chausson donc je laisse son mari me
taper avec le chausson il me brûle
complètement la peau au niveau des
fesses en claquant le chausson mais
c'est pas un petit chausson c'est les
chaussons avec les semelles extrêmement
raides donc du coup il me frappe avec le
chausson sauf que elle me dit que
finalement je vais quand même dormir
dans la cave donc je lui dis j'ai choisi
une chanson pour pas aller dans la cave
elle me dit tu vas y aller et là tu pars
tu vas dormir dans la cave et tu as
l'impression d'être morte en fait tu as
froid tes petites tu vois rien tu te dis
si je me réussit ma mère elle va pas
pouvoir savoir où je suis je
m'inquiétais pour ma sœur savoir elle
était où j'avais peur que je me rends
abandonnais dans la le chien qui est
avec nous était mieux traité que nous
là-bas on avait vraiment l'impression
d'être des moins que rien c'était
interdiction de parler avec ses enfants
interdiction de rentrer dans leur
chambre on avait l'impression d'être
vraiment rien du tout nous n'avons
jamais pu avoir l'occasion de protester
si ce n'est que d'essayer de retenir ses
bras quand elle quand elle nous noyait
dans la dans la salle de bain ou la
baignoire on n'a jamais pu protester on
n'a jamais pu se défendre de toute façon
on n'avait pas les moyens physiques de
pouvoir essayer de se libérer de ses
mains pour ma part j'ai jamais essayé de
me défendre parce que je la craignais
tellement surtout elle je craignais les
deux mais elle pour moi elle voyait tout
elle savait tout donc jamais j'aurais
tenté quoi que ce soit ne serait-ce que
de donner à manger aux chiens des choses
qu'elle me donnait qui traînait par
terre je l'ai mangé j'avais une peur
irrationnelle en fait pour moi c'était
impossible de protester j'avais parlé à
la psychologue qui me suivait dans
l'organisme de placement et j'avais
parlé à l'éducatrice qui était la
référente j'avais parlé au directeur de
l'organisme déplacement j'avais expliqué
qu'il y avait des choses qui se
passaient j'avais parlé de ce que j'ai
vu dans la chambre pour la petite j'ai
expliqué que on mangeait de la cervelle
d'agneau cru je leur ai expliqué que il
se passait des choses là-bas mais ils
ont rien pris au sérieux ils m'ont
dénoncé à ma famille d'accueil et le
soir quand je suis rentrée elle m'a dit
Lina tu as parlé et c'est à ce moment-là
que les sévices on recommence ils
étaient encore plus encore plus
difficile et la cave c'était devenu
c'était devenu ma chambre finalement au
cours de ces trois ans on n'a jamais eu
de contrôle par qui que ce soit de
l'organisme de placement pourtant
lorsqu'on était chez notre mère on avait
quelqu'un qui venait nous voir
régulièrement et là plus rien plus
personne on est laissé à l'abandon on a
personne de toute façon même si on
voulait dénoncer c'était compliqué et
lorsqu'on l'a fait on nous a pas pris au
sérieux donc et puis devant notre mère
on faisait bonne figure et puis on
passait des bons moments donc on n'avait
pas envie de vous les penser à rien
d'autre que que le moment présent parce
qu'en fait à chaque fois qu'on devait
voir ma mère elle dit elle me disait je
vais pas dire que tu as fait pipi ou tu
as fait caca sur toi donc en fait toi tu
dis ah je vais dire à ta mère je vais
pas dire à ta mère que tu j'ai fait pipi
que tu as fait caca sur toi je ne dirai
rien donc surtout tu fais très attention
si tu dis quoi que ce soit à ta mère je
vais tuer ta mère et vous allez revenir
chez moi donc tu savais que quand tu
partais tu pouvais rien dire parce que
si tu parlais de quoi que ce soit
c'était et même on avait 6 ans moi
j'avais 6 ans on avait 4 ans qu'est-ce
que tu veux dire en fait mais on est
resté quand même trois ans je suppose
qu'il fallait nous garder plus longtemps
possible deux enfants placés c'est
beaucoup d'argent donc j'imagine que
c'était ça la cause de ces trois ans et
séquelles qu'on a aujourd'hui elles sont
physiques et psychologiques savoir que
lorsqu'on était petite on avait
l'impression d'être morte de ne plus
exister on se parlait on se touchait
pour savoir si on existait encore et si
on était bien vivante on se demandait si
tu as envie tu me vois on savait plus si
on se voyait si on saute aussi si on
existait véritablement est-ce qu'on
était tellement laissé à l'abandon on
s'est retrouvé dans des pièces dans le
noir en plein milieu de la nuit c'est
assez compliqué pour deux petites filles
de 4 ans et 6 ans le quotidien il est
difficile ça allait vraiment des traces
que ça soit physique psychologique moi
j'ai des difficultés pour travailler
parce que mon corps ne tient pas
suffisamment je me nourris pas
normalement j'étais gavée à l'entonnoir
ça m'a laissé des séquelles physiques
donc je me nourris pas normalement mes
enfants me posent souvent la question
pourquoi tu manges écrasé ce que j'ai
réussi à leur dire c'est que j'avais un
bobo à la au ventre je suis constamment
en train d'essayer de ne pas transmettre
mes phobies à mes enfants et pourtant il
y en a des tonnes quand on a été enfermé
on devient claustrophobe quand on a été
enfermé dans le noir on a peur du noir
et tout ça c'est des phobies que je
traîne dans mon bagage et que j'essaye
de ne pas transmettre à mes enfants au
quotidien j'ai réussi à retrouver la
nouvelle adresse de notre famille
d'accueil je me suis présentée au
domicile pour tout simplement avoir une
réponse à nos questions on avait besoin
de savoir pourquoi ils nous ont fait ça
interrogé à savoir pourquoi il nous
avait fait subir tout ça la seule chose
qu'il a eu de me dire c'est les flics
vous ont poussé à parler il a même pas
une seule excuse il n'a pas mis un seul
instant il n'a pas bougé voilà j'ai pas
eu de réponse à aux questions qu'on se
pose depuis tant d'années on a un bon
espoir que le gouvernement s'intéresse
de plus près aux
dysfonctionnements de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance aujourd'hui nous avons juge
d'instruction qui a été saisie pour
notre affaire et donc on espère que ce
juge fera le nécessaire pour que la
lumière soit faite sur les sévices
tortures et actes de barbarie et violent
sur mineur qui ont été
faits par notre famille d'accueil le
mari et la femme on a un bon espoir que
le gouvernement s'intéresse de plus près
aux
dysfonctionnements de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance puisque on a une nouvelle
chargée la protection de l'enfance qui a
été nommée récemment madame cobel donc
je fais un appel à cette dame pour
qu'elle puisse faire le nécessaire et
mettre en place un protocole et un texte
de loi qui permettrait en fait de
sécuriser beaucoup plus les enfants et
d'accompagner les familles je voudrais
dire aussi à tous les enfants placés
qu'on n'a pas avoir honte d'avoir été
placée qu'on n'est pas des cassos et
qu'on peut s'en sortir dans la vie